e a ceia do rico meia-noite coisa linda
todo mundo espera meia-noite para comer
vem a avó trazendo aquele peruz do Forno
saindo naele negócio bonito ela com
aqueles negocinho de pano que tem nos
filmes a vó vem com os cabelinh bem
branquinho coisa linda o sorriso Ave
Maria parece um comercial da Corega fita
adesiva o po senhar nessa questão da
meia-noite aí já é um negócio que a
gente tem que repensar e a nossa
intenção de verdade é senhar da
meia-noite mas nós come que hora 9:30 a
gente até se esforça para comer
meia-noite mas quem é que abusa os
meninos Os meninos não aguenta o diabo
dos menino não aguenta ficar até
meia-noite sem comer Ah não Ah tu é com
fome ó hum comu menos um pedacinho de
frango e mãe bot com meu é mesmo ó mã
quando foi na hora que foi de tarde eu
nem lanchei ó e a gente vai na onda do
menino come também meia-noite a gente já
tá resolvendo a questão da digestão já
tá todo mundo assim ó h quinada e a uva
passa tá aqui na nossa cabeça no nosso
coração e na nossa arroz tá